the pm at a battery factory in coventry
desperate to get beyond his covered road
map
his big leveling up agenda stalled these
past 18 months
today an attempt to restart it it's the
mission of this government
to unite and level up across the whole
uk not just because that is morally
right
but because if we fail then we are
simply squandering vast reserves
of human capital no plan today rather a
promise of one this autumn
and a pledge to his southern
conservative heartlands too
we don't want to level down we don't
want to decapitate the tall
poppies we don't think that you can make
the poor parts of the country richer by
making the rich parts
of the country poorer but his message on
equality
dented by the football racism row you
talked in your speech about a moral duty
to unite and level up our country but
over the past month
you and your ministers have stoked
division
saying it was fans choice to boo the
team
for many people your own record
personally undermines your image as a
unifying prime minister
what are you going to do to change that
obviously i
uh you know i reject that or disagree
with it i should say
and i think that as a society what we
need to do is
understand that we've made progress in
tackling racism
i would say in my lifetime a lot of
progress
but i think we have to recognize that
there's still a long way to go
i don't think it's got a clue what's
happening on the street it's the people
that's doing all the talking
and all the fighting about it do you
sometimes worry that he's actually
stoking division in some of the language
he uses but also some of the actions of
his own government
i do wonder if it's the way the
government do things that they bring
things up in such a way
that it actually causes that division
labour calling out the pm for a lack of
a plan
well it's all sound bite and no
substance
um which is absolutely typical of this
prime minister
he's given a speech on leveling up which
has got nothing in it
all last night and today people have
been saying there's bound to be
something in this speech and there's
absolutely nothing
in the wealthy tory town of marlow
support for levelling up
but not at their expense somehow he's
got to
help the people at the bottom end
without necessarily
causing too much damage at the top end
which tend to be where the money is
anyway which trickles down to the bottom
edge
at the end of the day i think we're all
better off by everyone being a bit
better off and i think that that's
something that we should strive for as a
country
i think to be putting money into other
areas to give people
well let's call it privilege to give
people
the same sort of opportunities can only
be a really really good thing
beyond brexit leveling up this pm's
ambition for britain
but are still a divided country and the
question for this man
is whether he wants to be the one who
heals divisions or stokes them
beth rigby sky news coventry